Two days to go, Gandies.
Yeah.
True.
By the time I logged in this morning, I had already driven like 140 miles. So I had sent a message, me and Angela were chatting, and I happened to reread what I sent her, and I had to reply back to it and apologize because it didn't make any sense whatsoever. It was just random thoughts.
Yeah.
Oh.
Ohh.
So, I'm sorry that I'm sure I confused you way more than what the original question asked for.
PH.
You.
Yes.
So I'm on my third cup of coffee today, just trying to make it through.
No, no, no.
Okay.
I.
Yeah.
Oh man, completely understandable. We hear you, Canete. Just a few more hours to go.
PH.
Yeah.
True.
But thank you, thank you so much for taking time out. And we have got Natalie joined in as well. Hey, Natalie, thanks for joining in.
I did it.
Rick.
Hello, how's everyone doing?
Doing well, how are you?
Well...
Doing well, doing well.
And now we be expecting DJ to join in.
Yes, I'm expecting DJ and hopefully Matt to join in as well. I really, so we, as I've explained before, the other side of our company, they mainly do either multi-dwelling
Ohh, mate.
locations, networking and service for multi-dwelling units, or structure cabling.
Mhm.
That's kind of the bag on the other side. And we've had a bit of emergency happen on one of the structure cabling jobs they've been working. So they were, hence the early start and travel time this morning. They were kind of rushing to get so
OK.
Not you.
Kip.
They will probably be in the car joining was the last confirmation I got, but they should be joining us, yeah.
Mhm.
Thank you, thank you. For the heads up, let's just wait for a moment and then we can get started.
Yeah, what's what?
Give them one or two more minutes, and if not, then we could definitely get started. I'd hate to take up your whole day waiting when it...
For sure.
Nothing as such. We know these fires happen.
Unfortunately.
How have things been on Yeltsin?
Going well.
Rest, I let Andy and Natalie do the talking.
Yeah.
It's been better. I was literally dead last week, Janice. So I was out. My gums were in play and some type of infection. So glad to be back. Yeah.
Oh wow. I'm glad you are back, yes.
Yeah, I was like, I was out of it. Like really, you can see me and you can probably look at my face. I look like a chipmunk. I don't know. I mean, my cheeks are big as it is, but yeah, it is, it is. But yeah, we're back this week and we're catching up on things. So, yep.
Ohh, ****.
That is terrible.
It's better. How are you, Natalie?
You know, I had, I was on vacation last week, so my week was much better than yours, but I, I think you're confused too bumped. So, that's all. Yeah, I was, I was in Myrtle Beach, South Carolina. So that's where we have family over that way. So yeah, I got to hang out the beach a little bit. So.
Way to rub it in.
Oh, happened.
Nice.
It was nice. Now, now I'm back to work. Andy, you live at the beach, so you're fine.
I'm nearby, yes, few hours away.
Just kidding.
Probably it's closer than me. And then near me, I only have Texas beaches. So they're a little oily.
PH.
I think it was your son's birthday, Natalie, was it?
Amit.
I'm about four hours.
As it was 2 weeks, yeah, Ketan, so you near or you're in Alabama, is that that's where you're at?
Two.
I am, yeah. So I'm close to Gulf Shores, Orange Beach. Those are the closest to me. It takes about four hours. If I'm going to see sand, it's about four hours. But still end up in Florida.
Yes.
Bhanu.
Yeah.
I like it. It's pretty down there for sure.
I think your 4 hours is like a four hour drive in the US. Us in Manila, like a two hour drive. It includes traffic and traffic and traffic. So it's kind of nearby, but then the drive is a bit, I don't know.
Yeah.
Difficult.
Yeah, probably is. Are the roads as crazy as they are in India though?
No, not much, yeah, no.
Yeah, at least they follow the rules of the road.
At least they know how to use the signal light, at least some of them.
Yeah.
Hey, that's better than what we get here.
Yeah, sometimes. Although, Candice, when we were in India, like, there's no pedestrians have the right of way. Like, if you're trying to cross the street, like, you just gotta hope, you gotta hope that a car's not, like, they just, they just go. That's funny.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Ha ha ha!
Okay.
True.
The first time that we landed, I felt I thought that everybody was just mad at each other because they keep on beeping at each other, like loud beeps. I was like, okay, are we okay?
Yeah.
It's the national sound, yeah, for sure.
But it was a good time.
Are you, you guys aren't registered for Build It, are you?
I'm sorry, say it one more time.
Our event build it coming up in August. I don't think you guys have registered for that yet.
No, we won't be attending this year. My goal is to attend next year. We will be at the Evolve Conference in November.
Okay, okay.
But that's our big one for this year, but I'm hoping to
To be the ITBD one next year.
Yeah, for sure, because I think we're bringing about 12 people from our offshore teams. So you get to meet, you know, the people that you work with day in and day out as well. Yeah.
I love, would love that.
Yeah.
Ohh.
I say if you guys are ready to kind of get started, we can definitely do that. If they guys join in, then they can just catch up. Like I said, I was hoping that today they could sit down and meet everyone and really view their screens and see the information, but that has not
Yeah.
Looking like it's going to be the case.
Okay.
All right, let me see, because Sarbjeet should be hopping back and he pinged me, Kam.
Mm.
Andy, do you have the final version of the deck?
Yes, I do.
Okay, you can start sharing if you want them. Sarbjeet can.
Sure.
Alrighty.
Okay, so can you see my screen, ladies?
I can.
All right, perfect. Do you want to start this, Natalie, or should I?
Yeah, for sure. So thank you for joining us today. We're going to just go through Q1 and Q2, look at a few things, and I'll also give you some updates along the way. So you can go to the next slide.
So standard agenda for our QBR, so welcome. We'll go through our partnership, look at the business impact. We will do a performance review, go through some achievements and improvements, some growth opportunities, and then just next quarter priorities.
Next slide. So our value drivers, why you sign up with a company like ITBD by Design, one of the main reasons is to protect your gross profit and EBITDA overall. So with our solutions, you are saving 30 to 40 percent just on
employment costs and the resource fee right there. Business continuity overall, so different times, different resources. We are a 24 by 7 operation, and we're always going to be available, even if it's not your specific engineer. You always have the team here at IT by Design to just make sure that
anything that you need from us, we have it. And then just extend supported advisory overall. So on these calls, we like to have them quarterly. So just we focus on the service that's being delivered to you, but then we also just look at holistically how we can support you.
along the journey of being an MSP. Nice thing about us is we've been an MSP for a really long time. And then at least for me, like I like that now, I just talk to MSPs, but it's about MSP services. So just a different than like just working for a vendor or anything like that. Is there any other value drivers that you think?
top of mind or like a reason that you signed up with ITBD by design outside of these.
So last year at the Evolve Conference, two of our team members, Matt and Tim, they went and, you know, as you do, they come back from the conference, they were super excited, you know, just of all the things that they got to see and experience people they talked to.
And ITBD by Design was one of their main points, especially for Tim. When he came back, he just talked so highly. It was really excited about, I guess, whatever it is he said, I don't know, it could have been a booth. It could have been an actual, like,
Yeah.
you know, like, I'm not sure what he said there, but whatever it was, he was just really excited about. So when we were, hi, Matt.
Hey, guys.
So when we were looking to onboard a new team member, he just kept bringing it up. Bring you, let's look into it. Let's look into it. Let's look into it. And then we did. Tim and Matt, they actually are the ones who interviewed Angela originally. And once we got a taste of Angela, there was no going back for me. You can't convince me anything else.
Yeah, it's awful.
And she's been phenomenal, and her just her ability to pivot to look at a problem and not.
No, I love that.
immediately run, but think in terms of solutions and wanting to immediately come to a solution, find an overall resolution, be proactive. Those were key things for me that just it makes our life so much easier on a day-to-day basis.
And I know that she had the team behind her that pushed her and provided her with the support she needed to be able to offer us that as well as the support she had from our end. And I just really appreciated the structure and the team and I had a phenomenal experience.
Oh.
Yeah.
just overall. It really did make a difference, a true difference to the day-to-day functionality of our business.
The.
Well, good. And then thank you, Matt, because it sounds like you were a big advocate of ours coming back in. So thank you.
Yeah, no problem. Yeah, I second what Candace is saying. Obviously, Candace is a lot more involved with both of them right now, but I only have good things to say about both of them right now.
The.
That's good. Glad to hear. Everything okay on your side? I heard you had a fire today.
Yeah.
It's been one of those, one of those weeks, let's put it that way.
You're like, it's been it's been on fire the entire week.
Ohh.
TA.
Yeah, I'm just trying to, you know, just keep going right now. I'll probably be in Memphis tomorrow, I think, is where I'm going to be. So, you know, we do a different, a few different things in our business, and it seems like there's always a problem with one of the sides that, you know, you got to work with.
Is.
Are you?
Yeah, yep, yep. No, it's okay. I do appreciate you making time to join us today. But yeah, we were just going through some value drivers here and then you guys shared. So thank you for that. Andy, you can go to the next slide.
Mouse on the wheel.
No problem. I'm glad I did.
Yeah.
All right.
So, yeah, you're taking this one? Go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, I'll just take this one. So I just wanted to also share the key results that we delivered over the first and second quarter of the year. So we wanted to make sure or we wanted to highlight the infrastructure and system management. So Angela keeps the partner or your environment running at a full capacity.
managing servers, monitoring backups, and administering security alerts to ensure operational stability with the help, of course, of Candace on a daily basis. Aside from that, we also have project leadership. Angela leads implementation from start to finish, planning, execution, and closure.
We have also a resource who drives project, not just assist them. So this is about onboarding and offboarding partners and clients on your side of the fence, as well as vendor and application coordination. I usually hear Angela on the phone reaching out to the vendor and making sure that the relationship that we have with them
are okay and are, we're doing seamless assistance with whatever application we are currently updating and managing on that side. So Angela does that day in, day out. And if she needs anything, she usually just reach out to either Candice and myself.
TA.
Next is product monitoring, of course, and incident prevention. It has been a highlight as well of the past quarter of how Angela handles alerts proactively. Sometimes the client doesn't even know that they had an issue, but she was able to fix that and
keep Candace looped in on what's happening and ask for help. I think that's the main highlight of it is she knows when to ask and we were able to, or she was able to resolve that issue right there and then. And last but not least, one of the great probably news this past quarter is the team expansion.
Bye.
So this is not just Angela now. We added one more engineer, which is a senior system engineer, which is Jericho. We were able to successfully hire him, onboarded him, and we've been expanding the capacity and making sure that we demonstrate ITBD's ability to scale high value talent. So.
Yeah, that's the key value or key results that we delivered this past two quarters. Any questions?
Just confirmation of all of that.
If.
Thanks. Thanks, Candice. All right, let's move on. Natalie.
You're on mute, by the way.
Well, I was just, you know, saying what was on the screen there. So yeah, if you wanted to just give us a brief overview of what was really most important to you this past quarter. It sounds like you gave a little bit like Angela is fantastic, but anything else that kind of just stood out.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is.
Probably that change of the change in time, right, Candace, with...
And.
Yes, it was her. So we made an adjustment on our end and expanded our hours. And so we start now at 5 A.m. And Angela was very willing and open to adjusting her schedule to that earlier time slot for us.
And, in doing so...
She has now been able to provide our clients with if we're noticing, you know,
backups are, you know, issues with backup power supplies. So she's providing this information to our clients to where there's a transparency to their systems. Well, in that transparency, how we're going to fix it in a time frame of doing so. And so it's really.
helped us with our communication with our clients, with them understanding what we're doing. We're not just fixing printers, right? You know, so they're able to see that on a larger scale. And she's doing, she's been doing it in such a way that every time an e-mail comes across, I'm immediately going and like give her, that was so great. That sounds wonderful.
you know, good job on this because it is and it's making Matt's job a lot easier when he goes on site. It's not so blindsided when we're bringing up certain things or certain areas. And so the ability to be more transparent with our customers without it being
Oh, this is on fire. We're going to fix it. Oh, this is you're at 45%. Before you get to 50, let's look at these options.
I like that.
And and and we're that, you know, we're that far into it now, and that is because of Angela and the work that she's doing and her dedication to our clients.
Yeah.
I also think that on both sides, like our clients and, you know, Angela and Jericho, I think everyone's getting more comfortable with each other and it's not as much of a, you know, who is this person now all of a sudden and like they're doing a good job like kind of building that repertoire, whatever you want to call it, with everybody. So it's kind of nice they've.
Mhm.
They're adapting pretty well.
Through the Earth.
Yeah, I love that. So it sounds like the experience across the board is great for everybody, customer, employees, and the engineers, right? And you guys.
Absolutely. If we have someone that prefers to, you know, we had one customer that we were communicating, it was Jericho who was communicating via e-mail and the guy who reached out to me directly, he was like, I'm not always available by e-mail. Can he just not, can he not just call me? I'm like,
Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely. So it was just a simple, hey, this particular guy, you know, it's easier to reach him. We're going to work through his issues faster. Just give him a call. And he was like, absolutely. And from that moment on, that has been the case and we've not heard anything else. There's no additional complaint. There's no.
Oh, hey, this isn't getting done. You know, what's taking so long? It was an immediate fix, an immediate change.
and the client is happy.
And at the end of the day, so we all want, right?
No, I love that.
Kip.
Sure.
Yeah, for sure. And the proactiveness is great as well, just to be able to show the proactiveness and just see what that does for client experience at the end of the day is great.
It is.
Yeah.
All right, well, we can jump into some of the metrics then. Andy, back to you.
Sure. Thank you very much. All right, so we're going to look into their performance over the past quarter. So it's going to be Q1 and Q2. Wanted to make sure that we show you guys the numbers that they've worked on. We know that, you know, both of them are actually working on a lot of things currently, but we wanted to see
what those numbers are currently. You know, scope of work, this is the reactive support, their KPIs, and the hours that they cover. One of the highlights I have for over the first quarter, the ticket that has been managed by Angela alone.
She was able to close 220 tickets, so that means that she got more closed than open tickets because she's also working on the backlogs in the previous quarter. Second is 0 first respond time breaches throughout the entire quarter. So that means that everything that she...
handle everything that the ticketed are coming on her side of things, she was able to complete that. And also simultaneous clients between 8 to 13 clients covered each month with consistent daily presence. So she's available every time and any time on or whichever client we have or they have and she was able to assist them.
Last but not the least, I wanted to thank you guys for giving us, giving Angela 100% CSAT over the entire quarter. So first and second quarter, we already see that. So very, very grateful. Thank you very much.
All right, so let's move on to ticket and resolution rate. So as you can see, the first quarter, Angela is actually working more on a reactive ticket. So you would see two separate graphs. So we have January, February, and March. This is when she was working on a lot of tickets as a reactive support.
as opposed to the second quarter, which is a variety of reactive tickets, as well as small little projects that she worked on. So by second quarter, if I'm not mistaken, when I had a one-on-one with her, she's also working on emails that was being sent out to her.
She worked with him an hour or two hours, but she wasn't able to track it because there was no ticket at that. So there's an opportunity there, but the dip of the tickets that was handled is not really about her lack of things to do. It's just a matter of logging it.
Mhm.
Yeah.
on a ticket, but since you guys are moving to ConnectWise, we can easily sort that out when we work on a workflow wherein whenever someone sends an e-mail to a specific distribution list and then they send out and then they include an e-mail for ConnectWise, then it automatically log a ticket.
So I think that's an opportunity for us in the next few quarters.
Yeah, so summary for the first quarter, 219 tickets, 220 closed, 100% resolution rate. And for the second quarter, April was the highest volume. She had 63 handled tickets and close 65. May 28 handled, 28 closed, and June 20.
13 handled and 12 closed. So overall, it's 104 handled and 105 closed. This also include a lot of transition during Q2, but the resolution rate is still the same whenever she works on reactive tickets.
Any questions?
I don't have any. You're muted, Matt.
Okay.
I guess the best of us.
Nope, I'm good.
Okay. All right. Thank you very much. Let's move on to utilization trends. So same with the previous slide. We had a bit of a difficulty highlighting the utilization for Angela because of the lack of tickets on the things that she does.
Ohh.
But we were able to make sure that the billable utilization fell, not because, again, the actual performance is Angelo, but because of the significant volume of and track proactive work that for the second quarter. But for the first quarter, we want to make sure that we highlight his productivity 25.
Okay.
percent, 35 percent, and 37 percent, including, of course, the non-billable work that our servers, maintenance, updates, proactive alert management, backup monitoring, project leadership, and vendor coordination. So those are the things that is part of the utilization.
of Angela for first and second quarter. And we're going to do better when it comes to tracking it on this Q3 and Q4 to make sure that, you know, we, she was able to track those hours and those times on probably a project ticket, maybe a task, or maybe even an admin ticket.
on ConnectWise once you guys fully migrate into it.
Any question?
I have done.
Nope.
Okay.
All right, moving on, I wanted to just highlight engineers efficiency. So this is for the quarter one, billable versus non-billable. So Angela's billable output grew from 45% from January to March, which means he's, or while she's observing over 60,
hours per month have been tracked proactive work. So this means that SLAs are, we have no SLA breaches and 220 tickets that I previously showed earlier are being closed. take away is again the logging, the logging gap, not a performance gap, making sure that we
We log ConnectWise or tickets in ConnectWise and we'll show the real picture of what this engineer delivers. So this would include everything in the time entry and making sure that the ticket hygiene is there also. So yeah, that is for quarter one, but I wanted to also highlight
The things that she does on the Q2, these are the key project initiatives that she has that are not ticket work. So Barracuda, security improvements and parking controls, complete dental, this is a server update and third party app installation, quotes for new server and hardware replacement.
and client offboarding as well. For the month of May, server and backup incident resolution at MMEC, ConnectWise onboarding, continuation of hardware quotes, external vendor assistance, DMFs offboarding, and the complete dental offboarding continued. And for the
Month of June, monthly ConnectWise meeting, Altaro backup incident support, hard drive update, e-mail migration, WMD off boarding, and manage device updates. So Windows 10 to Windows 11. As you can see, this is a variety of small projects.
as well as admin, because, and I didn't even know that she's working on hardware codes. So these are a lot of different categorization of tickets that she would be able to track once we're in Connect twice. Any questions?
Mhm.
Ohh.
No.
All right.
And just wanted to highlight, I know Jericho started May, but I wanted to show a little bit of progress in there when it comes to the tickets that he handles. So for the month of May, so he partially joined May 12th, but then he was able to work 49 tickets handled and 42 closed.
And for June, it went a really, really upward trend to a point that he handled 87 tickets and closed 85 tickets. So that's a 98% resolution rate. I know that she or he just joined in, but then this is a really...
a good and solid onboarding curve for him. So for quarter two, he lacks one month really in quarter two, but he has a total of 127 tickets when it comes to the tickets that he closed.
And Matt, I know you were looking, like those numbers are wild, but a lot of that also includes S1 tickets, backup tickets, monitoring alerts. So not that we've had that many support needs. He's been working on some other outside. I could see the life draining from you, like what's happening.
Yeah.
It sounds like yikes.
It's not all support, it's across the board in all areas, learning, growing, assisting. So that's what that mix is, those numbers are for.
Yeah.
Variety.
Thank you for clarification. I was like.
I can see the panic.
Yeah.
You.
Like, Candace, what's going on? Hi.
Thank you.
See, I tell you, I do tell you whenever we're on fire, and this does not mean that we have not been on fire.
This is.
I, yeah, I know you, I know you've been not bothering me lately because of what's going on, so, but I was like, you could tell me some stuff, so...
Yeah.
S.
Thank you.
Looks good. No, I mean, that's an obviously an upward progression, obviously, all jokes aside. I mean, he's good. That's good. It's good to see it.
Yes.
Thank you very much. Aside from that, also wanted to include his utilization trend. So as a new hire, again, May 12, his utilization reflects the expected adjustment period that would include onboarding, training, and shadowing time as well, which are non-billable.
But again, it's completely normal since it's his first two months, roughly 2 months. So it's stable in June, even if the ticket volume has nearly doubled, which is a positive signal heading into the first full quarter.
Mhm.
OK.
All right, so far, any questions when it comes to the performance, the KPIs that we have shown?
I don't have any.
No, I'm good. Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
All right, so moving forward, so what we wanted to look forward to in the coming quarters is one would be the migration to ConnectWise. Candace usually, Candace and I talk about this every, every or during or monthly.
business service calls and I know that it's still in progress. And once we have that, we wanted to make sure that we integrated the monitoring tool that you guys use into ConnectWise Management so that alerts automatically generate tickets as opposed to manually creating them. So this allows both Angela and Jerrica to log the time per alert and have tickets close automatically when the alert is resolved.
Next is SLO ownership, because you now have two of them. We can strategically work with the two of them since Jericho is on the team. SLO ownership can be implemented. So that means that Jericho is the first point of contact, escalating to Angela as needed and ensuring the proactive work is visible.
and not buried in their reactive metrics. So once, probably after July, we can try to work on this, Candace, together so that Jericho at least can fully take care of everything that Angela has been working on in the past.
Mm.
Angela can take on the other side of the things that she should be working on as an ASA, right?
Absolutely.
Okay, cool. Last or 3rd apparently is a CSAT implementation. So I know that Candace here receives CSAT every now and then. Is it connected to ConnectWise or AutoTask for the time being?
Mhm.
It's connected to auto task currently. So and it generates once a ticket is closed. So it's really truly on the discretion of the client if they choose to complete the survey or not. And as you as you know, as soon as I get one, I immediately send it over.
Okay.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah.
Big applause to Jericho or Angela, and but we we do have.
Mhm.
In our connect was PSA.
That's integrated. So I think it would, we should have some better information for this once we get fully integrated into the PSA.
Kip.
Gotcha. So we'll be able to see those as opposed to you. I know that you have a lot of things on your plate on a daily basis. I don't want you to send individual emails every now and then. So at least once ConnectWise PSA has been settled and dusted, then we can look into having that CSAT implemented as well.
Hey.
Yes.
All right, last but not the least would be the advanced system engineer. Since we, when we hired and when we were talking about hiring another engineer for you guys, we did talk about, you know, making and or probably this would be a career development plan for Angelo and we.
did this. This is going to be the advanced system engineer. So we wanted to continue developing Angela toward the towards the advanced system engineer designation that we talked about. And again, we support with the structure development, expanding her technical scope and aligning her capabilities.
with Brian Creek's evolving infrastructure need. I know she does it already, the onboarding, the offboarding, all the little projects that she's part of. But I also wanted to know how is she doing based off of the expectation that we set initially when we started this, Candice.
I think she's doing phenomenal. Like I said, if there is something that is thrown at her or even a question that's asked, it there.
she immediately comes to some type of resolution or a solution, even if it's just as simple as give me a minute. But then in that minute, she comes back. She's like, well, can we do this, this, or this, or this over here work better? I think she's advancing well.
Mhm.
And I look, I truly look forward to being able to just offload some of the day-to-day little tickets from her and really give her the opportunity to make the systems as.
Mmh.
As phenomenal as I know that she can.
I see her grows and I think she's doing really well.
Banaag.
I gotcha. So probably once we connect for the next month, maybe we can see if Jericho, based off of your observations with Jericho, if he was able to take care of everything already that Angela previously does, then we can probably move ahead.
and move Angela into that ASA role and responsibilities as well. Okay.
Okay.
Sounds great.
Alrighty, any questions so far for Path Forward Q3?
No, I like what I see.
I don't have any.
Yeah, okay. Thank you very much.
Alrighty, back to you, Natalie.
Thank you, Andy. So yep, just some business updates. So where do you guys see the business going in the next three to six months?
Moving forward, I know we got another client coming on. Was that new client coming soon? We're hoping to grab some more clients. That's what we've been working on. But as of right now, we're trying to steady the ship. So, but.
To.
Mhm.
That.
Yes.
You know, we got...
We're trying to, you know, you've always heard the old adage of like, you know, there's sometimes you're just not a good fit for certain clients and it doesn't work out. I think we're kind of weeding those ones out right now. It seems like trying to grab ones that we want to be working with. I think we're learning this, you know, on the fly, but three to six months, I hope we're all a little less stressed and enjoying the holidays. That's my goal. So
Yeah.
Let's see if we could get there, but yeah, like to add a couple more clients, obviously, and get it running smooth. I think it's, I think we've learned that.
You know, dealing with a few clients and doing a very good job is a lot better than having a lot more clients and not doing a good job. So we're kind of finding that out that.
Let's start there first, right? So this is a new thing for us, but I think we're realizing that right now. But yeah, a few more clients and a smoother, smoother ship would be a nice thing right now. That's what we're striving for.
Yeah, it sounds like did you have to kind of redefine your ideal candidate profile or customer profile?
Yeah, I think so. I mean, everything we got handed is, you know, what we got handed when we acquired Ryan Creek and it's, you know, sometimes people have, you know, ties to, there's no loyalty from a few clients and we understand why there wouldn't be, you know, but we're working to.
Cool.
Make sure we're a good fit with the ones we have, and I'll build that load too with other with other new ones, so yeah, we we definitely realized that.
Yes. And then understanding how we want to do it and not just following the previous guard has been, you know, challenging for some of our clients, as Matt was saying, that aren't necessarily a fit on either side, you know, so we
Oh.
Learning and growing and understanding the type of clients that we want to work with. They obviously the type of work we want to provide, you know, service we want to provide.
Yeah.
and who you want to provide that for.
Now, are most of your clients set up just on like monthly contracts or is it like billable per usage?
That's A tricky question to answer because what we got was not a lot of information. Some people had no contracts. Some people it was it was insane. And you know, then the last guy that had it was telling people, you know, they might have had a contract, but you can get out of it whenever you want type of thing.
PH.
Yeah.
I think.
you know, coming from a business world, that doesn't make any sense to me at all. So it's kind of, we've got to work with a lot of those type of situations, and not a lot, but a few. So that's a hard question to answer.
Yeah.
Yeah, so you're really trying to lay a good foundation and weed out with people who aren't going to be a part of that.
Yes.
Yeah, absolutely. It's been challenging, but we, at least I can say on my end, I've learned so much about what we do and who we do it for by simply weeding out those that don't fit. And all of just the mess we kind of
Yeah, yeah, you know, I mean...
Yeah.
Yep.
grandfathered ourselves into with what we were handed. It's been challenging but educational.
And we know what we don't want to do and how to do that. So we need to know how to be better.
Right.
Yep, always one.
I think, yeah, you guys been very great, obviously finding you guys, and this has been obviously really, really, really helped us out. I'm involved in those evolve, that evolve group stuff for ConnectWise, and that's obviously been helpful for me to absorb the MSP world. But yeah, this is...
I think those two things, you guys and Evolve, have really helped me understand a lot of this stuff. So I think we're going in the right direction.
I agree.
Yeah.
I like that. Do you have any projects coming up, any moving on-prem to cloud?
Any projects?
We got, what's that, Wilco? Yeah, we do have, what's, I'm not sure what the, it's pretty basic onboarding this next one, but going back to what I was saying, it's a client we want to have. They're like a construction company and they're just not, they're not your typical dental doctor office that we have a lot of there. This probably come back to bite me, but it seemed pretty simple.
Yeah.
So, but you know, security.
And we have.
Like.
Okay.
So, that's really good.
If you do need additional support, we have a full projects team. So just any type of project, if you need help, we can scope it and then either white label, gray label, however you guys would want us, but more so our clients use us for overflow or I mean, sometimes we even take over all the projects, but.
any overflow, just let us know.
It's good to know, yeah.
Absolutely.
Ohh.
Yeah, and then I even have one of my other partners we saw kind of just a gap in like the overall like onboarding process. So we've added onboarding managers as well. And then how that normally is set up is we'll look at your existing process, see how everything's going to be going for you. And then whatever checklist needs to get done, if we have recommendations, we'll add to it. And then we kind of can develop that.
that person with you to if you don't have somebody like designated to your client onboardings.
Yeah, that might be nice to give that a go on one of them, you know, just to see how it works out, you know, like a little test one for it. I like that idea, you know, Candace, you think so? Maybe try that on one of them.
Mhm.
I do.
I think we should.
Yeah.
Get you guys to all forward for us, too.
Yeah. Well, we'll see, we'll see. But yeah, that definitely we can even just look at, I can have a team member reach out and we can just see what you even have going on and go from there.
Yeah.
Just kidding, Justin.
That's yeah, that's really not a bad idea. Maybe take a note for that. Maybe we can approach that and see just to at least have the conversation.
And...
Yeah.
And then as far as challenges, it sounds like the acquisition and clients right now are probably the biggest challenges. Anything like from a security or economy space that you're nervous about?
Can I see anything?
I would say those spaces, no, we have a pretty good grasp on those. For us, truly, the biggest challenge has been
the deeper we've dove into what has previously been offered and the way things were previously done with management and trying to correct those in a way that works for us while also making the client happy and finding in some situations we just can't.
and having to take the loss of it just not working. That truly has, in my opinion, at least been our biggest challenge with Ryan Creek.
It was we we inherited a bit of a mess, a bit of a mess, and and.
fixing it and understanding it and...
Doing it the way that we want to provide service has been the challenge.
Yeah, we hear that with acquisitions. Are you guys going to be doing any other acquisitions this year or what does that kind of look like long term for you? You're like, I'm dramatized.
Yeah.
No, absolutely not. Absolutely not. We might talk about it at the Christmas party for what the next year looks like, but that is it. We don't even want to talk about acquisitions.
Oh.
Okay, yeah, we'll definitely learn from this one, right? And um, and like we, we, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It's one thing, the technology, and then it's a whole other thing, the client base, and you never know what's going to happen.
Yeah, we've learned it's not easy. Yeah.
Well, yeah, yeah. I mean, I know it was new and this was all new to us at the time. So I mean, all joking aside, if there's a couple other smaller companies in our area, like who knows, you know, there's, we've already been taking a couple of their clients and you know, I mean, who knows really what the future holds, but we're not just trying to.
Rush to that one quite yet, so...
Good, good, good. Well, let us know. Any questions that you have, you can bounce them off me too.
Yeah.
Alright.
Thanks, Natalie.
All right, Andy, you can go to the next slide. So this is just a little bit about our AI. As you guys look to expand the AI division of your MSP, definitely use us. So we have the whole community aspect, which you're familiar with Builder. I'm sure you've seen emails about our AI accelerator.
Mhm.
That's going to be part of our build it as well, but the community is 1 aspect of it. We do consulting and training. Our AI managed services is actually a product, so it's a monthly reoccurring product, and it comes with two custom agents each quarter. You get 2 custom agents that we build for you, agents as a service, so we can just build out.
different agents that you're requesting. And then we are doing AI trainings with all of our employees as well.
How has your feedback been on doing that so far, both from your clients doing the AI agents services?
Yeah.
No, I think.
It's good. So I mean, mostly right now we're scheduling demos. We have a few projects that we've been able to roll out. The ones that are big right now are going to be the dispatching agent. And the second one, so the one we're working on is the revenue leakage. That one's, I'm implementing that with one of my clients now.
Uh-huh.
That one's going to be really great for them and our Helpdesk agent. So it also will troubleshoot tickets and give you recommendations.
Okay.
Okay. Yeah. Just curious. I know, I know everyone's coming up with something right now, so I just want to hear how it's going with you guys.
Really, it's putting guardrails around it for us, at least, like especially like internally and just making sure everyone is doing it safely. And yeah, any training or anything that you need, we're definitely here for you guys.
Right.
Yeah, I'm thinking of that as like a buffer for us, some kind of a buffer, just, you know, so things don't like slide by, right, Candace?
Uh-huh.
Correct.
We don't need to do Candace; we just need something with the hell back.
Are you guys using anything like plot or ChatGPT right now?
I mean, yeah, here and there. We're not super in our services, not to say, but I mean, we're using it, but.
Pretty, pretty low standard, to be honest with you, but yeah, I mean, every facet we're using it, but it's more of like how an old person would use Google, to be honest with you right now. It's kind of how we're doing it, but we're, yeah, we're we're getting there.
Yeah.
All right, well, your engineers do have access to like our AI trainings that we have. They may have already done it. I don't have the list. Andy has that. But yeah, if they're both completed and if you ever want to just ask them like, hey, is there anything with AI that you think that we can be doing and they have the time, feel free to use your engineers.
Completed it.
Two.
Okay, yeah, we're definitely not going to be the ones that are implementing it ourselves. We're going to be the ones using people like you guys to help us out. So. Yeah, definitely. We'll look into that. I like that.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
All right.
The.
Cool. So we do, if you want to, I can schedule, we can start off with doing like an AI assessment if you're there right now to actually just see where you guys stand and they built, we can build like a kind of a little roadmap of what it would look like if you used us.
Yeah, I'd like to do that soon. I don't, Canlas, I don't want to put too much on your plate either. So.
No, I say I agree. I definitely want to do that and would like to do it soon, but I would like to do it once we're in the PSA.
Okay, makes sense.
I don't want to look into what that would look like with our current platform, because it's not where we're going to stay. So once we get fully integrated into the PSA, I'd like to come back to this and look at that time. I think that would be the best plan for us.
Yeah.
Okay, and you're using ConnectWise, you're going to be ConnectWise for both now.
Yes, yes.
Okay.
Easy enough.
No issues there, right?
No, and they have some really great integrations. I'm really excited for things to be centralized. That's the goal is to centralize everything. I hate that they have to kind of bounce between multiple places to pull the information they need and to go, and it's all going to be kind of one-stop shopping.
No.
And I like that for the team.
Well, that's the well, that one's Zilfic. Zilfic was there when they were doing, I think they're working on, but...
It is, that's they were, that's what they acquired.
I remember talking to the last meeting we were at, and I just fly out and said they were trying to implement it right away, and I said, "Where are you guys?" and they're like...
The answer was like maybe 3/4 away, which is reliable. And I was like, all right, let's just let's come back to this.
Yeah, that's more of a learned AI as well. It will kind of learn once it's implemented and it's we've worked through some things with ConnectWise. But I really would like to look at some of the workflows and how we can make this the general day-to-day easier. Because I think I think Zelfic is more of a learned.
Edit.
Yep.
AI internally in the system opposed to something implemented to just make things easier.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. It's always good for you to kind of be the customer zero, kind of test all the automations out, and then you can start even talking to your clients and turn it into revenue as well.
Mm.
Yeah.
Yes.
Yep.
All right.
All right, next slide, Andy. So this is if you guys do want to set up any like specific demos for our agents. These are the ones that I have available to look into. And then I think the next slide is about Build It. But I know you guys aren't able to come, but if you change your mind, it is going to be an amazing event.
We are going to be talking about AI. The whole last day is just the AI accelerator. So you'll be getting tangible things to just yourself implement AI. You guys do get a BOGO and we have New York Stock Exchange is going to be our closing party, a Great Gatsby party. So it's going to be a lot of fun.
But our themes extend your thinking. So if you change your mind, just let us know and you can use this code.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
So yeah, I'll stop sharing. That's pretty much it for QBR. That's Q2 and Q1. Is there any questions so far? Would like to talk about anything at all? Moving on to Q3.
I don't have anything. I'm just really glad to have Matt, that he was able to join and kind of get to see the numbers and see a bit of our, you know, the time that we spend together, Andy, on our calls that we have each week and to kind of, because I talk about it all the time. And so for him to get to kind of see what it actually looked like and
That.
S.
Yeah.
And to to see the numbers and and how.
how things kind of generally work between us. So I appreciate that in his time and being able to hop in and kind of sit through this.
Yeah.
I've gotta gotta show her that I care. I'm just joking. No, it's hard. I'm glad I'm glad I was able to make it, guys. Yeah, definitely.
Okay.
I...
Yeah, I also appreciate how well you guys are working together too. So thank you, Andy and Candace. I know Sarbjeet was just kind of sitting here on hold the whole time, but he is going to be the customer success manager on your account, but he's on my team. So you may see, you know, as you add engineers, you may see some more quotes coming from him and then we'll do.
Yes.
PH.
Yeah.
But.
printables, but I'm always going to be around. I'm here too. So no, this is great. So thank you guys. I'm really looking forward to seeing how this partnership grows.
Yeah, definitely.
Absolutely.
Thank you both. Appreciate your time. I know you guys are busy all the time. I know Candice, Candice has played this really a lot. She drove a lot of miles today. So I appreciate you still jumping on this call. And as well as you, Matt, nice to meet you also remotely. Thank you very much. If you guys need anything at all when it comes to the
The.
Yeah.
You as well, yeah.
both of engineers that you guys have locally, just reach out to me. Candace know where to reach me. And yeah, we'll be here to support and hopefully scale up.
That sounds great. Thank you, everyone.
Alright, we appreciate your guys' time as well. Thanks, guys.
Thank you. Have a good day.
Thank you.
Have a great rest of the day. Bye bye.
Bye!
Bye.